me
僕は1950年生まれです
東京で新宿で生まれました
で new 整理のちょうど真ん中ですね
そこから入水後半をずっと生きてきました
でちょうど20世紀の後半って何があったかというとこれメディアが爆発したんですね
あらゆるメディアが登場しました
テレビから始まってインターネットまでものすごい勢いで世界中にメディア張り巡らさ
れた時代です
で黒子は
その今皆さんテレビとかねインターネット当たり前のように見てらっしゃい当たり前に
使ってらっしゃるんでもなかった時代を知ってるんです
なかった子だしているから新しいメディアがどれだけ素晴らしくどれだけ魅力的で
ただそのことによって何が壊されたかも知ってるんです
テレビが登場しました実は当たり前ですね生まれたと彼は多分テレビがあると思います
僕は小学校3年特にテレビあけました
それまで小学校通ってて学校に行って授業終わって帰ってくると
まランドセル部屋にパッドを掘り出して外に出たんですね
とみんな周りの子供が外出てきてでみんなでまぁその子供のコミュニティーですね
ガキ大将グループではができてそれでいいやなんか鬼ごっこしたり外高くしたり
まあそういう岩路地裏即したんですね
それがも楽しかったわけですでちょっとワルガキのガキ大将みたいのがいていろんな
遊びを教えてくれるんですね
とものすごくあの子供ながらにいろんな情報が入ってくるんで嬉しかったですね
ところはテレビが登場しました
家にもんのすごい魅力的な玩具です
学校ば帰っておりますみんな僕自身も含めて
距離の前に組み立てなっちゃうんです
誰も外に出た話と
外でで遊ぶよりもっとはるかに面白いコンテンツがテレビ何があったんですね
でもっといろんなことを教えてくれるいろんな世界を広げてくれる
そういうものがテレビにあったから子供心に子供たちと遊ぶよりも大人の世界
世界異論た面白いことがいっぱいあるということを教えてくれテレビに違う付いちゃっ
たわけです
そのことによって子どものコミュニティーはなくなったんですね
でそっからも始まりまして
中学生の時に
ビートルズが出ました
これも非常に衝撃的な出来事でまあそれまでエルビスプレスリーとポールアンカとかね
素晴らしい店いっぱいいたんですけどビートルとはちょっと違ったんですね
リバプールの不良なんです
で今まではスターでね
手に届かないようなアーティストだったーー
とビートルのはちょっとイカれた兄ギアんですね
ってが届くところにいたんですね
だから言ってミラー拡大小グループの web みたいな
それで高校生の時にビートルズが来日しました
武道館です
行けました
すごいでしょですが
今皆ライブとかねコンサートみんな普通に入ってチケットのねぴあちけっとぴあに取れ
ば取れますよね
当時はそんななかったんですよ
どうやってチケット取れば家財んですよ
でも人が来るん
もういてもたっ食べなくて武道館に行っただけですねー
門の前で入れてくれやって言ったら秀英さん神なった
ガードバーガー並んでですね
その時全国から200人くらいの同じような高校生大学生みたいのが厚罰なんですね
それで門の前で母はやってるチン中でうわーっ始まってもうみんなをなく泣いちゃっ
てるわけですよね
でこんなプラちっ超大変ですよビートルズ見るよりもすごい卓球だけですねでまあそれ
以来僕はあらゆることが起きたらその現場にいるっ
この現場の情報量とか面白いたとか高評価ンっていうのは
これはテレビ見たり雑誌見ても分からないですねなるほど現場に行こうということそこ
で発見しました
で僕は大学がありまして真っ向この時はさんが首で頑張っていったんですけども
大学入って文学部だったんで仲間属地です初めてですね
自分でメディアを作ろうと
ということで
同人雑誌を作りました
でまぁ当時は今のコミケみたいじゃなくて
まあ文学をね将来作家になりたいとかね文章書くの好きだと言うが
まあそういう連中が3人で集まりましてですね原稿を持ち寄って同時挿しを作っ
僕も評論がきましたデビューさんです
でその後
4高2ですねミニコミっていうことが出てきたんですね
マスコミに対するミニコミ
で僕は何となく同人誌っても古くと黒くてですね
ミニゴムって何か新しいそうだなと思って磯小屋か僕らの同日読み込みしちゃいました
で太って気が強いんですけどしばらくしてからね
同じように現行集めて同じように印刷して同じに配る
行為同じなんだけど同時にちょっとミニコミてなんか根本的に違うなって感じがしたん
ですね
何だろうと同人誌っていうのは作品のクオリティを求めるんですね
小左側なりたいつの良い文章を書くと人が主役なんですね
とはミニコミてそうじゃないんです
メディアは主役なんです
こういう雑誌を作るからかきたやつ明日マレットです
そうすると1回しか考えてみう指示連載する奴もいる
そのメディアが主役なんですねこれもまたなんかすごい何かあるなって言うな
直感があったんですね
でちょうどその頃ロックの分娩とカバーってきまして
アメリカでウッドストックっていうコンサートがあってそれが飛び火全日本でも
400円とか
日々開こうとかそういうところでコンサートいっぱいあったんですね
でライブがあったんです
そこに行きました通いました
そうするとそれまで弱とかクラシックとか
芸術音楽っていうのは菊川ただ鑑賞して素晴らしい白砂がっていうなことなんですけど
ロックの解除は違ったんですね
やってる安も聞いてる相撲一緒になって同じ空間をを十字させようと
その客も参加してこの時間と空間を盛り上げようというような動きをしたんですね
だこれはそこへと
でたまたま越冬地新宿に伝説的あるあの総理とって有力視さがありましてそこで dj
やってたのが渋谷家とところで論理だったんですね
僕大学生でしたで出会いまして一緒に雑誌を作ろうと
でその雑誌は
その頃の音楽雑誌っていうのはまあ人のスターの愛と六角写真趣味でありますと
が評論家が分析するようなインテリ雑誌と
をそういうロック座しかなかったんですけどロックのイベントと同じようなライブと
同じを雑誌を作ろうと
ボール楽器も弾けないし歌も下手だとロックやりたいと
そういう思いをみんなで投稿してこいというような
そのステージのような雑誌をつくろうということでロッキングオンという雑誌を創刊し
ました
それが1972年です
まだ生まれた人を言ったりと思います
もうロッド路の出版社ですけどもまぁそれを作りました
で
まず今でしたら新しい毎週ベンチャーですよね
新しい事業を起こすとなると
みんな頭いいから投資家にそのメイクとかですね
クラウドファンドであるとか
いろんな手法があると思いますね
ところは当時僕がそういう情報はなかった
まあ取り出して出せば売れるだろうというなんだかよくわかんない自信を持ってですね
やったら全く売れるどこじゃなくてハイフォンもできない
3全部作って1000部肺胞者も大変なことで何百深い分できない
でその方が僕の部屋にどんどん積まれてですね僕はその上に布団ひいてで塗りました
[笑い]
まあそういうが時代をはじめましてでそのうちにお金がなくなっちゃう
あの現行の中もちろん張らないし何も貼らないわけですけれども
印刷で貼らないところができない
で印刷費が払えないでしょうがないんで
当時今まで atp があるんですけど昔は社食っていうタイプにさせ買ったんですね
僕はその
日暮里の日田町の車車検に修行に行きまして覚えちゃって
写植機買って自分で餌
印刷しました
雑誌を出すためにさっそく覚えた男って言うんで業界でよかっ祭
変ないいんですけれどもハードから言うと私の際あるでしてくれ
でまぁそれを社食やりながらまロッキングを続けたんですけど
70年代のロックシーン2のはねまあすごい時代でした
まああのいろんな新しいミュージシャンがどんどん生まれてすごく面白かったんです
けど
june +と一人二役なって板書業界なってですね
あの大スターになってもうコマーシャルとなってくるとで
エマーあっパンクが出てきてですねそれに刺激されたこともあって
音楽外そうと
ロックって音楽だけじゃないだろう音楽の突破口だけどもっといろんなロックがあって
いいだかと社会そのものがロックじゃんロック日なくみんなが参加してみんなで
盛り上げる社会服務じゃないかということで
音楽外した当講座所棄却して宝島っていうところに提案してポンプと雑誌で
えっ
紹介しました
でこれは今 sns とか言いたいとがありますけどとにかく初めから俺まで全部投稿
です
テキストも写真もイラストも全部投稿
毎日僕んとこ200数200投稿が来るんです
僕朝から分ソヨンちゃんです
皆さん今メールが100通来て大変だとか言いますけど私は何百通といろんな人がな
投稿を読み続けた人生です
それをやりまして
すぐに問題点ぶつかりました
何でしょうか
これはね紙メディアなんです
でもちろんネットもないですよね
メールもない郵便です何価格で車
なんか悪口書く奴いるんですけど乗るのが2ヶ月後なんですね
だから全然炎上しないんです
2ヶ月怒ってる奴いないんですね今ネットおごるの合う瞬間系なんで瞬間ですわういお
菓子で起こるから援助すんですね
あれに彼のそれはまたするんじゃね
であのまあそうじゃったんですけどやっぱり神の限界になってボスが出ちゃうんですよ
もう何百つは包んだけど載せないのはに300数がギリギリなんですね
ってあのイヴァン読者から基礎かあさんどういう根拠で選んでいいんですかって言うん
ですよ
余計なお世話だと思うんだよまあ僕が逆の立場からそう言いますよね
でまぁしょうがなくてまあいろいろ議論をしてですね
2つの方法考えました一つは神は限界だといくら退場したってこれ限界だと
でもやがてまぁ当時パソコンモニターともなかったんですけど
やがて僕はメディアの免責って言いましたけど無限のメディアの面積を持つメディアが
できるはずだと
それはたぶんコンピューターだろうというふうに麻雀後半に思ってな仲間達集めて
コンピューターの勉強会を開きました
だから人とはまあ将来的に停車メディアの可能性というのを見据えて実はもう一つ全く
違うことを考えたんです
これはオフ会です
というかとその逃亡雑誌ですね何月何次男分
どこそこの喫茶店でこの映画について話し合いたいという information で
あるんです
そこにあってもあるんですね
で集まってきてそこで喋れなかったらお前は連打からソロボスというだと
妻時間と空間を限定した投稿雑誌を作ったん
これを僕は2000回ありました
全国ですねもちろん僕がやったんじゃなくて読者がやったんですけど
2000回以上行ってきました
でまあそういうことをやりながらインターネットの状況が来ていま
ある意味では僕の理想とする誰もが自分の思いを
発言できて世界の人に盗撮できるというそういう社会システムができたわけですけど
半分喜んでて半分絶望してます
その絶望の部分は基本的には僕自身もそうですけど今のインターネットって今日でリ
ツイートとかシェアが多いですね
もう90%それですっていうことは責任とってないんですよ
その情報に対してあの一番初め発言者責任取るだろうけどそれを流すだけですから
って流したものが溢れてるんですねた当然そこにはフェイクもあるしでもある
むしろ手間の方が広がっちゃうんですね
まあそう言うな状況でこれは変えられない消せない
ですからその上にですね僕はもう一度
酒豪がはっきりしたインターネットを作るべきだと思う
今匿名性のインターネットの草の上にすぐをはっきりした
インターネットスクールベティそのその場合絞っていうのが今のようにですね
イデオロギーとかその建前とかそういうのに縛られた知識の情報じゃなくてそれぞれの
人が自分で生きている現場の実感と体験
ん
それをベースにした守護のある情報は止めたいなと思っています
えっ
here till とのそのレバーみたいなちょっと phone
2日間100人が10分づつ者プレート
いうのをやりました
でそれやったらですね今年集まった連中が居るもやりた俺もありタイツって
今年だけで
丹波で2回ありました京都でありました
和歌山でありました
南ある防いでありました今後広島であります
東京都まいります
秩父でおります今勝手にどんどん広がっちゃったんですね
その時も言ってるのは
それぞれの自分の生き方と丹波行った時に側への味とか学校の先生とか自分の立場で
自分の未来を語る
そういうあのフェスを始めていますこれは言ってみれば僕のインターの情の深いです
で多分僕が今やろうとしていることは僕が子供時代
テレビが r 文って言われた小さな地域のコミュニティ
ある渤海復活させたいと思ってます
[拍手]